Edward season you look beautiful as  always you know that you were my first  question you were my first crush to  don't do this he's too weak for you the  things you love about him now are the  things you all hate I really wanted to  be this person that you thought I was  when you love someone you have to be  careful with it you might never get it  again my ex-husband used to call me a  nocturnal animal I didn't know you had  an ex-husband did you love him I did  something horrible to him I left him in  a brutal way  are we gonna do it's question of how  serious you are about seeing justice  done you're crazy like you're being sane  I'm gonna live to regret this  he's gonna be rough for him out there  not knowing how it's gonna come nobody  is away with what she did but buddy  ex-husband used to call me a nocturnal  animal I didn't know you had an  ex-husband I've been thinking about him  a lot lately and then recently he sent  me this book phase written